[Music]
well good morning I'm going fishing I'm
gonna go hit that spot that I jumped up
last night and only have an hour to
before Tommy and Becca wake up then
we're gonna do some more sightseeing but
it's a beautiful day not too hot yet
good feeling all right there's two carp
right on top of where I was chumming so
definitely gonna catch right there as
soon as they get my rig set up all right
got a landing net some American gear
British carp rigs some brand new reels
this is my panco jello in corn bait the
jello in Japan doesn't have as much dye
in it so it didn't really turn pink but
it smells strongly of strawberries so
what I'm doing here is I'm using
Japanese rod and reels to fish with
British rigs and American bait that
pretty much sums up my fishing style
Japanese landing nets are so cool I love
these things
here we go
all right got a big ball of bait right
there see how long that takes
it just my ear
go ahead and grab some breakfast which
looks a lot like my bait 50 nut butter
sandwich
I'll tell you what these river carps
sure our Pisces not a very big boy but
man he put up a fight and these guys
have definitely seen a few books in
their lives they're definitely
definitely lying shy this one was
trailing a bobber when I reeled him in
we got that pulled off him as well so
he's that felt the prick of a hook
before there we go
off you go I'm gonna fall in here that
wasn't a very big carbon he really put a
strain on my gear if I catch a
20-pounder I'm gonna be in deep trouble
well guys it started to get real hot and
I need to get going home only efficient
for about two hours had to fish on
number of bites landed one not too bad
not too bad had loads of fun finally got
a picture of that Oh son show the giant
Japanese salamander so that was cool
giant salamander there he goes right
there but I'm gonna try the skin
tomorrow morning so we're gonna get more
chances to do this I think well it's
8:00 in the morning and I'm already a
big ball of sweat but it was totally
worth it planted another carp so that's
my second carp up caught here in Japan
well I'm gonna go back to the house and
have some breakfast take a shower and me
and Tommy are gonna go
juice more sightseeing we have four days
left here in Japan but we're kind of
booked up near the end so this is our
last wild-card day where we can do
whatever we want me and Tommy to the
gion district don't have a lot of plans
so we have some fun
[Music]
so me and Tom stopped a pharmacy to pick
up some sunscreen cuz you know we kind
of need it and I bought this stuff it's
sunscreen plus cooling which sounds good
but I think it just got menthol in it
now my face feels like it's both cold
and burning at the same time it's like I
smeared icy hot in my eyes it's not the
greatest sensation nicely they gave you
that fan didn't she
well there you go keep cool buddy so
this right here is the key Odom shoten
it's just basically a lot of stores and
retail shops people from the Sun and
rain and it's just a great place to see
what everyday Japanese life feels like
this oh that's cutie so I bought myself
a big cereal bowl because the one I
bought for my last trip to Japan broke
like a week ago so that's my rebound
ramen bowl and the sunscreen is stop the
burning it actually feels kind of nice
and cool
maybe it's not so bad just a little bit
I could do this all day long
[Music]
me and Becca have a tradition every time
we go to a foreign country we pick up a
kids book at least one from that country
so we've got an awesome collection of
books from Europe and Asia and all that
so we need to do that too so I'm gonna
start hitting bookstores see if we can
find something so that right there is
kind of like an antique book store
we got an antique Japanese book about
mythological baby that rides a bear and
has a giant battle ax dad seemed pretty
cool to me all right this one bicycles
aren't allowed to be ridden
this is a place that makes taiyaki which
is like a pancake with bean jelly inside
the shape of a fish eat picky only guy
she wants it oh it's sweet beans he is
shaped like a tie which is a pink zebra
so this right here is one of the biggest
show death of our Bennet it's a little
west of the qilin district it's open and
it's pretty awesome
mm nice store they've got all sorts of
cool knives they got a Tonka Wakan Kitty
die see there's a comma over there
stuff for cooking chisels carpentry
those acts oh look at that there's like
a bearded cleaver that's the key gogo
comedy night was up axes and look at
those sheaves okay I think I ended up
buying out half the store here this
place is amazing
he's nice gorgeous there's a bunch of
Damascus steel over there I don't need
it I want
you go in there and you spend attempt to
change in the store and you act nice and
don't rub people the wrong way it's a
really good chance that they're gonna
knock off some price that they can it's
nice having the bike here when Tommy
gets tired of walking we could put him
in the seat and push it so here west of
Gihon it's just an absolute network of
these little show tents lots of food
stalls some of them are more touristy
some of them are local but some of them
are tight and some of them are spread
out but you could spend days exploring
all of these all right well we found a
little place to eat here they've got
some yucca dole and beef curry which
both sound really good over the Aqua
dole means parent and child on rice so
it's chicken and eggs but nice kind of
western but it's cool so this is rice
and beef curry salad and this is
oyakodon which is egg and chicken on
rice there's some pickled vegetables and
we've got a little soup here as well
people that restaurant were just so nice
old older couple grown children and they
see Tommy today run out bring them out
some scrambled eggs and some broccoli
just started trying to bring out things
that he might leave
like it doesn't charge us for any of it
just
really nice that's just kind of typical
experience here in Japan everyone's just
super nice if you just try a little bit
to appreciate their culture and speak
your language people just bend over
backwards for you
[Music]
so do i so coming under my one on this
car
chotto chotto decade are you going which
I described are no wider no no no
wired2fish
yellow mac pursuing okay from the
hatchery hatchery jargon birthday river
is so clear look at all those koi piled
up right in there
I can see them all it's right along the
rivers turning out to be great oh that a
pretty cool ball to put in the basket
[Music]
alright time to put on some more burning
sunscreen
whoo birds man's water is clear part
there cut their cut beer
hmm that was a long trip we did a lot of
bike riding well we're gonna take a
little rest or play a little bit and
then once Tom he's rallied we'll see
what he wants to do this is Japanese
bread Leo think that is have a piece of
that buddy George this see here's the
popsicle the Japanese popsicle week
there you go yep thank you
where'd you go meet mama at the
convention center and try to get some
fries a little final site team judo is
beef on rice it's like braised beef with
the gravy on rice really good anything
with the word don't on it means on right
so naughty bone is not eel on rice
NEADS parent parents and child upon
rights you means beef dude old bebop
rice all right we got ourselves a couple
few Don's to go and Tommy's here on the
lookout for another vending machine that
boy loves him some soda and I don't
blame him
where'd you pan put it in there another
another brown one I want to try
something they haven't tried before all
right we're gonna try some cooties told
me it's all here this is actually it's
sweeter it's it's there's like no pulp
in it it's not like normal tomato juice
which is really thick this is just like
tomato flavored water almost but there's
something else something kind of sweet
in it
hey yeah well let's go hit the toys yeah
we've got some for you Beck has been
wanting to see this place with a
thousand gates like the Shinto shrine so
that's
[Music]
all right well here we guys alright
fushimi inari shrine and we're gonna go
see the thousand please we're gonna see
like ten of them and collapse from
exhaustion and give up and go home
but still alright guys so this is a
toilet II it's right there it's
associated with Shinto and the Shinto
shrines have them the Buddhist temples
have a different type of gate but if you
see this
it's Shinto most of Japanese people
intermix Buddhism and Shintoism there's
a saying that's very popular it is that
you're a born Shinto you marry Christian
and you die Buddhist that's because when
babies are born you do a Shinto ceremony
Christian weddings are very popular when
you die you hire a Buddhist priest to
come to the funeral
this corridor of toadies apparently goes
or quite some ways you can do make a
real big hike out of it we are grossly
out of shape Becca's recently recovered
crippled and Tommy is whining so that's
gonna cut our journey short but that's
okay because we're having fun
oh no you talk to yaki here only a
semester see it's not mayonnaise and
bonitas flakes seaweed what's not to
like
now one thing about takoyaki is you
always eat it at a temperature that's
called your mouth or burns you here we
are at Kyoto tower we're gonna try to
get to the very top if we can
[Music]
there's our house
that is where the monkey park is gonna
head home by taxi gonna eat some food
listen to our book relax we got some
foods we're back home we're gonna relax
and we'll see you tomorrow morning
thanks for watching we hope you enjoyed
this video if you'd like to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to check
out part 7 of our 2018 world tour where
we spend five weeks traveling the world
fishing and having adventures if you'd
like to see more great fishing videos
check out my other channel the catfish
and carp YouTube channel thanks for
watching